I think India can become a super car
because it has the population and the
kind of ovulation and the makeup life
and I think in order for India to do
that it's really going to have to
concentrate on education far more than
studying the past strikes me that the
education in India test you started the
basic level elementary school work its
way through the middle school and high
school I worried less about universities
in india both because i think they will
and can develop faster and because
university education for Indians can be
done up off floor so you just have to
hope that India's education system will
equal X lies as a superpower